whatever to say is certainly worth
taking my mask off and I would ask if
anyone agrees with what I say if you
could please donate a minute because I
have a little bit longer just two
minutes would be appreciated if not I
understand my name is Dan roll does
anyone wish to donate a minute could you
okay anyways my name is Dan roll and I'm
here today in 2020 we need grit
we need good news and I was not
expecting the excellent news that
Michele Fiori was stepping down as mayor
pro-tem in the city of Las Vegas it is
welcome good news but this is not the
first time let's not forget that in 2015
Michele Fiori called her black
Assemblyman colleague a colored person
and then told us all to get over matters
of race in color because we had a black
president Michele Fiore loves to
associate with cliven Bundy a alleged
domestic terrorist and let's not forget
that clive in bundy said that black
people were better off as slaves because
at least they knew how to pick cotton
and you madam mayor chose that woman to
be your mayor pro-tem this is the same
woman whose business was shut down by
the state of nevada
and told us that cancer was a fungus
that could be cleared with baking soda
it is not ironic to me that Michele
Fiori wraps herself in the thin blue
line claims to be Pro law enforcement
but conveniently forgets the fact that
she was expelled and condemned by law
enforcement in 2016 for saying sorry
next no no no you not no no I'm sorry no
it's ahead of time wait alright wait one
second we have to get your name ma'am
excuse me
my name is Annette Walker no you didn't
get it up front because they didn't know
you it was when you were going on into
your comments
no no we're just following the same for
the Netwalker you know yes ma'am okay
thank you
Michele Fiore in the middle of a
budgetary crisis she's walking out
that's awesome Theresa
[Applause]
[Music]